have you given much thought to your
carpet lately well you should because
clean carpet can change the look of your
home and help with indoor allergies also
just benefit your overall health for
your family and today we have our guests
from Zerorez who can help you with all
of those things we have Ben and Doug
McKee to tell us more welcome back you
two good to see you okay I just asked
where did you get this dirty carpet from
and they said Ted's house I've been to
Ted's house his carpet is clean thanks
to you guys but talk to us about that
right now I'm suffering from allergies
so badly and maybe if I just get my
carpets cleaned that could help right it
can you got to understand in your home
or at your business your biggest air
filter is actually your soft surfaces
your carpet your upholstery drapery is
collecting all the dust dander and
pollen that's floating around getting it
professionally clean will let it go back
to doing its job of filtering the air so
that your air stays cleaner I love zero
res because you guys aren't using those
artificial detergents and so hopes
you're cleaning our carpets with just
water tell us about that it is we have a
patented cleaning process it's we
utilize what we call ZR water and this
technology allows us to clean without
the Soaps and what that means for you at
your home is that your carpets Dry soft
at a touch there's no chemical residue
left behind and there's my favorite part
is there's no weird odors it just smells
fresh I've noticed when you guys clean
my carpets uh they dry a lot faster than
they would if you were using soaps or
surfactants it does it and our whole
process like we have our truck mount is
powered by the truck's engine it's like
having a 300 horsepower vacuum so not
only does the carpet get clean it dries
really fast I want to talk about your
customer service a little bit when
people come
zero rest it is we train our team day in
and day out on how to provide the best
customer experience we talk about
communication skills and things like
that so when we come to your home we're
treating you like family nicest people
ever let's get a little demonstration on
what they can do for you this is always
my favorite part of the interview
because it's the one swipe this is the
dirtiest carpet I've ever seen but not
for long let's take a look let's see
what we can do just with one swipe I
that is so amazing to me
go two swipes even better and you don't
just do carpets right no we clean every
surface out there so from top to bottom
we can get your air ducts clean we can
clean up your your upholstery like we
talked about uh we even clean commercial
properties oh yeah so if you're a
business and you want zero rest to come
in they can do this for you and you
usually come with a special tell us what
you wait hey you're welcome
what is the special for that you guys
have to offer so right now you can get
your carpets clean as low as 35 per area
and we're gonna throw in a 300 square
feet of tile and grout cleaning
absolutely free minimums apply but give
us a call definitely take advantage of
that
again zero res for sponsoring this
segment check out their
out there's a cleaning of a hundred
square feet call them today at
702-840-333 or go online to
zerorezlasvegas.com minimum of supply
Las Vegas now we'll be right back